les forces du craignent elles résistent
dont le dombass volodymyr zelensky l'a
martelé lors d'une conférence de presse
mais le président ukrainien le reconnaît
on à la situation à l'est est difficile
à ces vers automne est ce que vous savez
nous tenons bon les russes sont plus
nombreux et plus puissant yves bilan et
poteaux gêné chez selon les autorités
ukrainiennes d'intenses combats de rue
se déroule dans la ville clé de
severodonezk les positions des deux
armées évolue d'heure en heure alors que
les ukrainiens revendique le contrôle de
la moitié ouest de la cité les frapru
sont également atteint la ville de
drouges kiffca à 100 km du front ici
comme ailleurs dans le donbass les
habitants ne peuvent que constater les
dégâts causés par les bombardements
vous pouvez voir vous même ce qui vient
de se passer
puis dire je n'ai plus de maison alors
que je suis vieille
dame s'il vous plaît aidez nous avons
besoin de matériaux pour le toit pour la
maison il ya des gens qui n'ont nulle
part où se réfugier travail à la
conquête de c02 n'y est que permettrait
à l'armée russe de prendre une sérieuse
option sur la région de lougansk qui
compose avec celle de donetsk le dombass
tant convoité par le kremlin